thank you thank you all very much for
that very warm welcome
we are indeed here to discuss a topic
which has been in the public mind both
here and in the United States really for
most all for a good chunk of the last
year or so it is as the title puts it
Revere or remove the Battle of a statues
heritage and history and really our
subject in a way is memory and how we
grapple with that publicly it's one
thing how we grapple with it in our own
personal lives but the larger question
here is how do we deal with memory in
the public sphere part of that is going
to be about statues but we're going to
also I hope explore other areas in which
we have to reckon with our past and with
me our four people who do that
professionally and are really
extraordinary extraordinarily well
placed to wrestle in public if you like
with these ideas not with each other
not going that crushingly down market
just yet but instead with these ideas
because they wrestle with them all the
time just to say a word or two about the
the background to it I think when the
idea first took root it was partly
because here in this country we'd seen
the roads must fall campaign abroad and
here hitting the headlines partly when
it demanded the removal of the statue of
Cecil Rhodes from Oxford's Oxford's
Oriel College where which of course of
which he'd been a major benefactor
because of his record as an imperialist
but also in the United States last
summer August it reached an island pitch
in Charlottesville where there had been
an argument raging for months and in
some ways for years about the statue in
that city to Robert Elia General of the
Confederacy and therefore of course a
defender of slavery those were two of
the sort of pitched battles but behind
those have been a whole lot of others
where people have been debating you know
whether they keeping these statues in
some ways endorses those historical
figures and yet on the other hand does
the act of removing them seek to erase
airbrush distort the historical record
the arguments are strongly felt on both
sides as anybody who will have followed
our Twitter feeds over the last few
weeks will have seen this is an issue
that stirs up strong feelings so we're
going to discuss them all the plan is
really to use our first chunk of time
having a discussion a conversation up
here and then of course in intelligent
squared
fashion I will open it up for
contributions and thoughts from all of
you which of course are then bring back
for responses here so without further
ado let me introduce to you our four
speakers and I'll move from my left to
my right no political reading there at
all
first up is the historian and author of
the best-selling world history the silk
road's he is a senior research fellow at
Worcester College Oxford and professor
of global history at Oxford which sounds
like a very big job he is Peter Franco
pan
next up is the author of the critically
acclaimed keeping their marbles how
museums acquired their artifacts and why
they should keep them she is a
consultant on cultural policy and an
honorary fellow in the Department of art
history at the University of Edinburgh a
warm welcome for Tiffany Jenkins
on my immediate right writer and
broadcaster who's worked long on things
as a barrister West Africa correspondent
of legal affairs correspondent for the
Guardian was also a correspondent for
Sky News but came to even greater
prominence would be more recently with
her book British or British on race
identity and belonging which recently
won the juror would prize for nonfiction
a for Hirsch
and completing our panel the
award-winning historian and broadcaster
whose latest book black and British a
forgotten history was accompanied by a
BBC two series of that name and of
course known to many here as one of the
presenters of the BBC's new landmark
series civilizations he is of course
David on a sugar so so a stellar lineup
as I said all people concerned with
these questions of history I just
thought we would do an opening thought
from each of you and we'll keep it quite
short just to sort of set out a bit of a
stool
are there any statues monuments
memorials even just one that's currently
in this country the UK that you would
rather was not here and we will start
with you David
this tattoo that I would remove that I
don't think she'd be on public display
is one I went past in Bristol in a taxi
about three hours ago which is the
statue to Edward Costin to me it's a
very simple case many of the figures
that were going to debate tonight they
have two sides to their story
they did great things but they did
terrible things Costin doesn't have
another side to the ledger here and the
world African company the most infamous
the most prolific slave trading company
in British history he's responsible we
estimate for the deaths of around 30,000
people who died in slave raids died in
the holds of slave ships and he has
statues built after it built in honor of
him buildings named after him
because he gave lots of money to the
city he was born in Bristol
that's all he decided that he wanted to
whitewash his legacy and make sure that
he was well remembered the statue in the
centre of Bristol was built in 1895 he
died in 1721 we have no idea what he
looks like never mind whether the statue
was an accurate representation of his
likeness this is somebody for whom there
is no mitigating argument because
statues aren't about remembering history
they're about memorialization they're
about saying this was somebody who we
should revere the statue says he's a
wise and virtuous he's not wise he's not
virtuous he's a killer
and his statue shouldn't be on public
display on the streets of Bristol but it
should be in a museum because when we
talk about toppling statues very few
people are talking about their
destruction we're talking about taking
them off public display taking them out
of the arena where they're celebrated
and there were thousands of statues in
museums across this city and of course
Britain
I think the statue of Edward cause near
Bristol should join them Thank You
Tiffany
Jenkins there's there are lots of
statues people like Coulson who
committed a number of evil acts there
are also very ugly statues there are
lots of forgotten statues I see no
reason to tear any of them down
certainly I wouldn't have a problem with
benign neglect or even defacing them
because this is a public space
I say no I see no reason I don't think
it's a radical act putting them in a
museum I think just relocates the debate
from the public sphere to an institution
and I think there would be a danger that
you know museums are not the most
neutral spaces either
I think there's almost like a danger of
policing people's responses to them and
relocating the culture wars to museums
which i think would be a problem just
let them let them go I don't think I
kind of the politics of symbolism is not
really a very progressive course there
are far more important things that we
could be doing okay will benign neglect
that one and we'll let that we won't
clean and polish that one um I have I'm
not most of them I don't think there's
any that I'd actively kind of put
flowers at the right I don't I just
think in a way that there is they're in
a public space I think David made quite
an important point that they're in the
public space so I kind of think is up to
the public to respond to them as they
see fit I mean I live in Scotland and in
Glasgow there's the statue of the Earl
of Wellington and he's had a cone on his
head for decades the council tried to
elongate him so they couldn't put any
more small cones upon them I think
that's entirely fine I don't think we
should revere or be reverential about
these things I think the past is a
complicated and messy place and it's
quite good that it's under our feet that
we pass it I think it's quite
interesting actually the Carlsen is
quite interesting I think in I grew up
in Oxford and I think the Cecil Rhodes
statue is quite important for telling us
how it was built who went there you know
it's that kind of complicated aspect of
showing us our past is quite useful good
we're definitely going to come back to
all of these efforts esle roads because
that's a great starting place for me I
would have no issue with the removal of
sessile roads and the reason is not only
that he was an imperious he was actually
more like a Buccaneer he was regarded by
his contemporaries in an era of empire
and imperial expansion as an
embarrassment to Empire because his
behavior was so out of control his
racism was so unpalatable so I think
that he's an interesting character that
goes to the heart of this question of
whether somebody like me is imposing
modern standards onto a different era
where there was a different morality at
play by the standards of his time Rhodes
was regarded as a problem let alone by
the standards of 21st century
multicultural Britain and the thing
about Rhodes a statue in Oxford and his
presence in Oxford is that this is still
an institution that excludes people of
color that excludes the descendants of
the kind of racist white supremacist
system that Rhodes did so much to help
build that hasn't addressed the
inherited intergenerational injustice
and inequality of that system and so
it's it's it's it's a double whammy it
compounds and already painful injustice
for students struggling with an
institution that hasn't repaired that
wrong so then have a figure like Rhodes
in a position of reverence and I think
what Tiffany says about benign neglect
is interesting but for me the reality is
when somebody is on a plinth in a public
space when you crane your neck to look
up at them that is an act of reverence
whether you like it or not I don't
believe we have a sophisticated debate
around the statues that are in public
places we simply walk past them and look
up at them I would be much more
interested in putting them in a place
where there is an educational process
there is a genuine conversation and
there is a context thank you Peter
what would you nominate for not being
there removal is such a loaded word
if you could may waive a magic wand and
there was one there was a statue on
Memorial you'd rather not have around
what would it be well I don't want to
either trivialize tonight's debate all
these are very important questions and
in fact it's about it's about history so
I mean if we were shutting on this then
run but you know it's just too statue
you know hands up who's been to Paris in
this room or Rome can you name any 19th
or 20th century statue you saw in those
two magical cities you know we don't
look at statues particularly I mean it's
it's exactly right when of when a figure
becomes important because it's a matter
of discussion like roads then that's
prominence becomes an important topic to
talk about which is what we wanted what
I want to talk about this evening but
by-and-large
London is filled with 19th and 20th
century statues almost all of them are
men almost all of them are soldiers
almost all of them make no difference to
our daily lives so if there is a
question about editing the past but my
view as a historian is that a job of a
statue is eventually to form right
that's what that's why you put a statue
up you put a statue up to commemorate
someone and then time it could be years
it could be decades it could be hundreds
of years you know that doesn't exist
anymore that's that's that that's the
process of the winds of history so there
are specific cases to talk about slavery
exclusion I don't want to let my
university be shot out on its own almost
every single Center of Education of
excellence in this country has the same
institutional problems about exclusion
that deserve to be talked about so it's
unfair to just pick out Oxford it's
unfair to just pick out or real college
but Rhodes has a particular
lightning-rod but I can show you statues
in Oxford within 50 50 miles of here
hundreds of them that could generate the
same sort of discussion about people who
did power things and I think it's
therefore it becomes a question of who
who do we try to prioritize in those
kinds of discussions and until you do
that it's just a piece of lead or a
piece of copper or piece of bronze that
somebody paid for and no
bothers looking at do you want to come
back on this point of whether or not it
matters you know Peters essentially sort
of saying you know there could be lots
of little cousins everywhere and unless
you make a rather an argument about it
no one really is that bothered yes we
can I first come up on the idea of
benign neglect because of course most of
these statues are listed and our friends
in historic England would be on your
back if you did allow them to to rot
away so the sponsors of this debate
wouldn't allow that statues for the most
part don't matter we'd walk up as we
walk past them every day they're gray
they're boring almost all of them are
terrible works of art the one thing you
almost never hear when you talk about
removing status is oh please don't it's
a wonderful work of art imagine if we
were talking about removing paintings
from the National Gallery the art
defence would be the absolute forefront
of our thinking most of them are really
now he is entirely right most of them
are benign but they're benign to me but
I can accept that some of them are
benign to other people now my accent my
background is not West Indian or African
American and African my ancestors
weren't enslaved but I know people who
are West Africa West Indian heritage who
live in Bristol who talk about the
genuine emotions that they feel when
they walk under the statute of the man
who was the governor of the Royal
African company the company that
transported author ancestors into
slavery than any company in British
history did though it did so with royal
patronage burning the letters RAC on to
the chests of men women and children of
the age of nine I believed them when
they say it hurts that they feel
humiliated by Colston on his pillow I
don't personally I go about my life
cycle around Bristol I'm a TV producer
so I obviously spend more time having
focaccia oh and goats cheese and I have
a perfectly nice life I don't have a
chip in my shoulder I'm not oppressed by
these turkeys but I'd know people who
are and I believe them that's all I'm
asking that we believe people when they
say these things are oppressive and of
course everybody believes that certain
snatch you should not be allowed to
stand uncritically in public without
some sort of context realization Germany
is full of the wonderful and I think
artistically very valuable statues
abraca Hitler's great sculptor far
better sculptor than most of the statues
we see in London nobody believes that
those data should be taken out of the
storage facilities that they were in
hidden away most people don't know where
they are outside Berlin and put on
public display we wouldn't dream of it
because those studies are embodiments
something which we understand is morally
reprehensible yet we struggle to make
the same connection with slavery that's
the problem
I believed in too
I believe although that this may be a
debate that seems to be advanced by a
vocal minority people feel very strongly
about it and do feel oppressed by those
statues no no I believe them I believe
them however I don't think we should
organize public space around their
feelings I think to do so would to be
kind of weaponized this debate and
emotion and that would be that'd be the
wrong thing to do I think you have to
ask is this the best way to deal with
inequality today I would say no it's
certainly not the problems that Peter
talked about after we talked about it
certainly isn't is it a dangerous
distraction I think so
because what we're effectively doing is
enslaving ourselves by the past we are
not moving on from it you know it isn't
no you do have to ask why is this debate
happened now those statues have been
around for a very long time and I think
it has come in a context where the past
has become almost like the solution to
contemporary problems when they were put
up it is not true that this is suddenly
a manifestation of liberal political
correctness that's just not true these
studies were contested there at the time
let's remember that the first roads must
fall campaign was in the 1950s and it
was white boy
Stewart students who wanted road to move
because of the Second World War
it's just not true it's historically
untrue to say that this is a modern
contemporary frivolous debate it's as
old as statues that's why they topple
that's why they fall and it's part of
the process Peters talking about
that statues inevitably fall they fall
out of favor or they fall apart this
debate is part of that process it's not
some sort of anomaly or some sort of you
know artificial situation created by a
bunch of Guardian journalists that's
this is this is history
you say that like as if it would be a
bad thing for the young I just wondered
were there one factual thing which I
didn't ask you about the time but I
wanted to why did it take till 1895 for
them to commemorate Colston because the
reason constants were memorator has
nothing to do with the Bristol in the
18th century when it was the biggest
slave port in the North Atlantic trade
it had to do with a balance of power
within the merchants ventures who ran
Bristol in the 1890s and it was taking
Halston and his philanthropy and taking
claim of it that statue has nothing to
do yeah with Carson and his memory it
was a way of using him to to win a
battle of power and to just just to
inform this bit of the conversation why
don't you cuz I know you've written
about this say something about the
context in the United States about these
Confederate generals on horseback often
which people assume were built in the
Civil War and therefore we mustn't take
them down because the Civil War is a big
part of American history the history of
their construction is slightly different
this is another myth we presume these
statues are much older than there were
we almost always presume because they
meant to look old and they where though
and they look gray and very quickly we
presume they're old most of the statues
in the Civil War which was 61 to 65 were
not put up in 1866 when people were the
wounded and and the the the veterans
were still alive there's a great burst
of statues being put up around the time
of 1919 at the end of the First World
War around the same time 21 African
American soldiers were lynched for
wearing their uniforms in public having
got back from the Western Front these
statues were put up then because there
was a moment when there was hope for
black rights for black voting rights and
these statues were imposed on the south
on majority black towns as a way of
saying you stay in your place these
statues have a function the function is
not to remember the Civil War it is to
intimidate southern black Americans and
the second burst is in the 1960s when
civil rights began so some of these
strategies are actually younger than the
people defending them in rallying around
with Confederate flags around they're
plain saying this is my history they
younger than you are and not your
history your your history Peter and NF
yes I think that that's right I mean you
know it sort of surprised you I gotta
say that the certain solution ifs in
suppose you could have one it's about
education and luckily now today things
like slavery are taught to school
children which they weren't when I when
I was a boy and you know that think
that's a very important part of our
chapter it is important I think to
connect these kind of signal events of
the American Civil War and the
Confederates with the fact that almost
all of the founding fathers who led
American to dependents were slave owners
and took America to independence in
order to protect slavery right so that's
not to say that the the Confederate
General said have their own Hall of Hell
to live in you know as a historian I
don't have any problem about like you
say of condemning act and views for what
they were at the time as well as what
they are today but you know where does
that leave Washington where does that
leave Jefferson to great slave owners
who have capital said he's named off the
massive memorials but because they they
managed to take America to a different
kind of pathway their role in slavery
their role in what it meant to be black
in America or African African in America
gets washed over by the fact that they
get they gather sainthood so it's how
one Cal calibrates those two so it's not
not to bring everybody up not to bring
the Confederates opportunity to justify
them but you've got then got a call a
spade a spade and you know I personally
have worked on medieval slavery you know
don't go to Venice you know one of the
world's great slaving sensors those
palazzi that look great on the canals
the way which we call people the Slavs
today that is where we get our word
slave from you know we don't think about
that because we don't get taught that I
those kids are disconnected in the idea
that slavery is something that's
important to understand in a whole range
of situations and circumstances so as a
history you know again it's a very
boring thing to say as a historian and
I'm not trying to not take sides but
it's that if you're going to do it then
do it properly and explain that it's not
just about bad men in the 1860s happened
to lose a war it's about the history of
America from its foundation was all
built on all of this and that all the
people are involved including the
founding fathers who appear on the
banknotes who appear in their monuments
have cities named after them who don't
get vilified they don't have to pay the
price and probably if but by the logic
of you
argument they should well no because the
very first thing I said is there were
many historical figures that have two
sides to their ledger now Washington
when the British are in New York sends
spies in to try to capture the human
beings he owns but Washington's also
want to thank most remarkable figures of
the general and we love generals we love
the America today's story
was exactly that they provide from
Bedford for a Confederate General he
murders the african-american soldiers
who fall into his hands who's one of the
founders of the KKK I don't think
there's two sides to that story but I
think the key thing is here's the these
statues they weren't built to remember
to memorialize Nathan Bedford Forrest
they were built to intimidate African
Americans who were beginning to just
beginning to grasp so then you know I've
got a question for this somebody like me
who has questioned many of our statues
is weaponizing public spaces to me these
statues have been as David's just
explaining a means by which public
spaces have long been weaponized and
there's almost this kind of tyranny of
the majority that the majority people
don't see this perspective of people who
walk around feeling tyrannize and
intimidated and oppressed by these
figures and this isn't just a
straightforward race issues you take a
figure like Cromwell I didn't know for
almost all of my life that he was
regarded by so many Irish people as the
first modern genocide or figure and the
idea of having his statue in front of
the palaces where of Westminster is the
kind of father of parliamentary
democracy was seen as a painful and an
offensive thing by so many people I
think that the reality can be taken away
then I think that this is healthy that
we have this discussion and but there is
I mean it's good that you raise
education that is part of this I think
if we were all honest and educated and
we were learning about the full
historical record of these figures as
British people it would matter less that
these statues on their plinth the fact
is that we have no context we have no
education and we live in a place that
Revere's them now the reality is that
there is a location in general be take
it should chrome will be taken down I
personally don't feel oppressed by Colin
Rowe because it's not my history but I
have a lot of sympathy for people who do
so I think you know I would like to hear
from them on this issue and I think they
should be more debate about it my
personal history is a black British
person growing up in this country was
that I felt that my the the the role and
contribution that people of my heritage
had played this country is completely
invisible in public spaces military men
many of whom were Imperial conquerors
are venerated and displayed and put on
prints all over the place in their
subliminal messaging of that is that the
people who have contributed who deserve
respect in this country as a child
growing up who had no political agenda
whatsoever the messaging that I received
was that the people who are people of
Worth who are worthy of historical notes
who we should venerate are these white
militaristic men and I think that it
goes to the very heart of what kind of
nation are we who do we value who do we
venerate at the moment it is white men
who led imperial military conquests and
who I think are totally out sync with
the idea of who we are as a country so
just on that point would the remedy for
that be to add lots more statues of
people of color more women people who've
made that contribution or will that
remedying not be complete until some of
those white militaristic men as you put
it come down yeah I think it's an
interesting question what to do whether
we should just kind of have in have more
people of color I have more women public
spaces would get very crowded if all of
the people I would like since hatch well
suddenly pop up I was in Germany
recently just outside Berlin at the ship
and our Citadel yeah and it's a
fascinating place the second rice
statues that commemorate Imperial
figures actually many of whom have
similar backgrounds to the kind of
people that we have on Flint's in London
were taken down after the Second World
War and put in a museum there they be
taken off their plinth cleaned up you
can get up close to them you can touch
them and I found it a really powerful
experience because the reality is and
others have said it we don't really pay
that much attention to our statues we
don't necessarily take good care of them
there they're a bad combination it's the
worst case scenario where they're
visible but they're invisible so it's
kind of recognition with without
education in Spandau you actually learn
about them you talk about them you think
about the historical legacy and I think
that's a far healthier way of engaging
them you actually learn
thing and you put it into a contract it
says let me get you on this Tiffany on
the nail or something else you want to
say but I just want you to respond
anchors earlier on when David initially
said you wouldn't have Colston destroyed
he would haven't put in a museum you
didn't take up that suggestion because
you said that's just to relocate the
argument but then later a Lewis said the
trouble is with them being statues
they're in positions of reverence
because we're craning our necks looking
at them and if you have them in the
museum you're looking at them in a
different way if I've summarized what
you said so what just on that point
about not destroying them but putting
them in a museum where you can be almost
I to I with them rather than looking
upward wouldn't that be a good solution
I think it relocates the debate from the
public space to the institution and
museums are very good at putting things
on pedestals so I don't think he would
anyway be more critical and I there's a
kind of self flattering element to this
kind of place because we know better
because we're educated unlike the kind
of mash you know unwashed masses who
couldn't possibly look at Coulson and
think in any way that he was a vile
human being or question their their
their past or their relationship to him
so I think there's a kind of there's
like slightly paternalistic attitude
towards it but I just want to take up
this point as to whether this is a new
thing or not I mean David's right that
these statues have always been the focus
of contestation as have objects and
indeed in museums but they haven't it's
this debate has not dominated the
political sphere quite so much in the
way that it has done in the last suit of
20 or 30 years and I think we have to
see it in its political broader context
my mind is that the past has become the
place for politics both for left and
right they fight over which version of
history they prefer so the right used to
venerate nice white old men and talk
about imperial conquest and grandeur and
the left now come in and talk about the
wrongs of history I think that more
Eliza's history and it has taken a step
away from envisioning a future society
you know we used to have the saying Joe
Hill used to talk about do not mourn
organize I there is suffering there is
hardship but we have to do something
about it and now we have this kind of
flipside almost of that which is that we
must organize to mourn and I think it
benefit
nobody been a certainly does not benefit
the victims because in a way that they
are kind of fatal fatalistic about their
past dominating their present they can't
even walk down the street without
feeling vulnerable that's no sense of
agency there and I'm not walking down
the street having a hard time oppressed
by these statues maybe you did say other
people were and you were cell mindful of
them this idea that this is a current
debate that you keep coming back to that
this is just now we've gone up quite a
few decades unusually in this country
without someone dynamiting a statue we
blew up started our statues were burned
up in Ireland statues are blown up after
the First World War
statues are having a really easy time at
the moment again it's not historically
grounded it's not based on historical
analysis that haven't been blown up the
statutes aren't at risk they have too
much of a history look at the Gordon
riots look at what's pulled down it's
just not true
the point I'm making isn't just about
statue so it's the growth of reparations
politics you had a flurry of apologies
in around 2000 is Blair cetera so it's
not statues isn't just about statues
it's about the pace of the park Tiffany
the fear that somebody like me is
moralizing history history has been
moralized just in favor of the people
who killed enslave and colonized and the
evidence I have of this is is that I
have raised the question of whether we
should look again at the legacy of
Nelson whether we should look again at
the legacy of Churchill if you raise
basic points of historical record
against these figures you are met with a
torrent I mean hundreds of thousands of
trolling comments that that demonize you
for introducing facts into the bait and
the reason is that people have so been
moralized into unconditionally revering
figures like Churchill which is a hugely
regressive move because actually at his
peers at the time were fully aware of
his deep flaws of his very problematic
racist attitudes so racist that they
clouded his judgment about important
strategic matters at the time we've gone
back and you give us an example just
invade Nelson Germany so for example we
are a Marine he was Nelson who was
Churchill's colleague in the cabinet
that he tonight of the same generation a
Tory on the right
wrote in his diaries that he feared that
Churchill's racism towards Indians was
so rabid an out-of-control dit was
clouding his judgment about shipping in
India in the second world war it was
also said by other contemporaries that
when Churchill began warning about
Hitler in the 1930s nobody took him
seriously because he'd used the same
language about Gandhi and you know this
idea that he was so he'd so lost
perspective because he was bound up in
these ideas which were already by then
deeply outdated Nelson was using his
position in the House of Lords to
campaign against the abolition of the
transatlantic slave trade at the time
when Britain was only a few years away
from achieving abolition so even at a
time when Britain was divided there was
this huge groundswell among
working-class people among parliamentary
elites favouring the abolition the
transatlantic slave trade Nelson was
pandering to the interest of his friends
and and in-laws in the Caribbean so this
is a person as well who at his own time
by the standards of his era was out of
sync now all I'm suggesting is that we
introduce those facts into the narrative
around our relationship with these
figures and when you do that people
react with extreme hostility and the
reason is that they have been moralized
and beside this idea that these figures
are untouchable they have an almost
iconic deified status so history is has
been moralized as being weaponized
against the oppressed who have been
forgotten who are not commemorated and
who and even though Peter G said we do
learn about history in school most
people in this country know a far
greater amount about abolition than they
do about the four hundred years of
slavery that preceded it and how can it
be logical to celebrate having abolished
something that you fail to really
acknowledge you played a role you just
broke before we get
we're going to hear Peter respond we can
happy to respond in a minute you said
there something I don't anyone could
disagree with which is more facts and
more knowledge and more context but
because we're in the realm of the
concrete and the marble and the bronze
here just tell us how that
contextualization and information say in
the example in the case of Nelson what
practical form would that take because
I'm just picturing Nelson's column and
how we look up how would you make that a
more informative thing and then we're
happy well I actually had great fun
making a documentary for David's
production company which is going to be
on channel 4 in a couple of weeks in
which we and I don't want to give too
much away but we did something to
Nelson's column that I think really
helped contextualize his legacy so watch
this space to find out more we don't
have a museum of empire in this country
isn't that remarkable arguably the most
important aspect of modern British
history that has made us for
multicultural global power that we are
400 years of Empire there is not a
single museum to it that is the level
and extent of our major if we were to
have such museum it would be a very
appropriate place to put a statue of
someone like this thank you Peter
well you know it's this by the way is
why you need to fund historians at
universities I'm serious you know we
have a government of whom 21 of the 23
in the cabinet rated humanities and
they're all voting only to invest into
STEM subjects these this is what my
caucus what our colleagues do in
universities day in day out almost all
of them unsung most of them not invited
to intelligence squared debate
most the much more eloquently than I am
not sure about the other the others on
the panel but you know these things they
are it's not just that they're important
they're also incredibly interesting you
know it is important to be challenging
using new pieces of information new
tools new resources and so on and so
forth
I absolutely completely welcome it and
only an idiot would discard someone's
opinion without evaluating everybody
when I was talking about Churchill will
sit there thinking well okay oh no no
Tommy nursin may be Boris wouldn't be so
busy comparing us of the church all the
time or maybe he weren't you know who
knows
the comparison God you know and so I
think I think it's terrific that we have
these kind of discussions in a in it and
they're they're important topics for my
two cents and it's it's a very boring
thing to say you know the world in the
21st century is on the move you know I
think despite the importance of slavery
despite importance of evaluating Nelson
there are more important regions there
are more important people's to be
understanding their history rather than
the incessant navel-gazing that we want
to do here and I can tell you if you
write about Henry the eighth if you
write about the first world war there
are these top a church he'll it'll sell
by the bucketload because people love
that stuff
you write about China you heard about
Russia it's not the revolution right
about Iran no one in this room can tell
me the name of a Chinese emperor can
they please shout it out put your hand
up okay
or a Persian ruler that's not the last
char nothing we are totally ignorant add
subs are enough not just sub-saharan
Africa add almost any other place in the
world outside Western Europe in the US
with North America and we know
absolutely nothing so this question of
refining and drilling down how do we
Iranian it feels to me a bit like
shuffle in the chair that the deck
chairs on the Titanic
you know Britain has to understand other
people so I absolutely welcome these
kinds of questions about Churchill and
Nelson and Saul and many others and
slavery and it's important that work
gets done and it's important gets done
by the best scholars of the day and they
need an audience but there it seems to
me that there are other interesting
topics that lose all that oxygen and if
we're going to talk about diversity if
we're going to talk about dignity of
other people's cultures the fact that no
one here can tell me the name of a
contemporary Russian artist Chinese
novelist you know these are a Middle
East in a musician artist composer from
the Middle East poet you know we are
absolutely and I throw it that is a
Meyer is a special ism that throw in
throw in other cultures throw in Africa
throw in Egypt from West Africa thrown
whatever you like that level of
self-indulgence where we are only
worried about war on past looks like and
how do we feel a bit better a bit worse
about it
yeah means like we're not keeping up
with what's going on although it is an
OK
well I think it is it is natural thing
for any society to be interested in its
own history and to be more engine in its
own history well we excessively
interested we are made a point of being
absolutely narcissistic and that means
but of course
Leonel shut up the impact of being
narcissistic is that there are half or
whatever it is who love their own
reflection Churchill they're Saints and
then half who feel that they're excluded
because we keep her in the same stories
again and again and again who are the we
is the question that comes out you know
whoever it is I think it's I'm like like
the same way we're it's it's this is
about public debate but I can't see into
anybody else's soul or mind Tiffani
raised before two other areas that are
in the non concrete area where history
is important and we're going to get onto
those in the minutes before we open up
more broadly but just before we leave
the business statues we've talked about
the ones that are already there and
whether they should be or not and and
I'm not ignoring what Peter said because
I think there's a way of coming back to
this but especially that didn't get
built in this era in Westminster there
was a proposal for a statue of Margaret
Thatcher the Westminster Council said no
in January of this year because they
feared it would be in exactly you're
saying has always happened the target of
protests and V&O vandalism and so it
wasn't built there is a statue to
Margaret Thatcher inside the Palace of
Westminster so MPs and visitors can see
it but actually on the street in the
public sphere there is not one and I'll
start with you I thought because you
were saying you would like there to be
some more women around so should there
be a statue for Margaret Thatcher it's
not my politics that any women is
necessarily representative of progress
for women and she would be a great
example of why that is not the case
where's mr. Smith the council by the way
are excellent at saying no to statues
they resisted the Mary Seacole statue
which is one of the very few statues of
black women in Britain and they also
resisted the homeless Jesus statue in
which I it was took even me by surprise
so they've got hard hearts at
Westminster Council
love to hear from anyone from the
council if they're in the room in the
quite in the QA I know I don't think we
should shy away from divisive figures
because I want us to talk about them but
given that we have a problem where
people who have right-wing imperialists
and oppressive histories are over
represented in statues I'm not sure how
erecting a statue of Margot Thatcher
would rectify the situation isn't the
problem not just that David come on it
isn't them the problem it becomes quite
a partisan thing where you know the left
will always say we only one deaf people
left will be able to deny Bevin that the
right would want Margot said I mean in
in a society how do you make sure that
there are figures that we can come to
some kind of agreement on people in many
spheres of life you have to deal with
this as a day to day as part of their
job it's immensely difficult there is a
real problem that if we are going to try
to repopulate the streets with a counter
statue for every statue then we better
give up on cars I'm trying to get to
work and building any new houses I think
this gets to the heart that's it problem
see I don't think it's that important to
debate I think the debate about status
is actually debate about history and I
think that they are what we're doing is
we're a country that's changed
enormously trying to find a new grasp of
it history and statues are just a
lightning rod that were using to do it
and I think that's what's really going
on but the thing about statues is that
they're pretty nerve it's a pretty dead
form of memorialization look at the
fourth plan it's not joyful doesn't that
fitting isn't that appropriate for us
that it changes and it's inventive and
it's clever that's really in keeping
with what were our societies like that
but monumental memorials that up that
are heroic memorials yeah they really
were just what were too cynical were too
kind of we poke fun too much for that
same thing they look silly I mean we
mentioned traffic cones in Edinburgh I
wrote in The Guardian I spent my entire
teens and 20s in Newcastle making sure
there's a traffic cone on George
Stevenson's head every Saturday night
and we prided ourselves that we didn't
go home after the nightclub until he had
a traffic cone on his head
biggest biggest we just instanc 17 we
knew they were there silly yeah so
heated the debate is about history not
static you say Oh Tiffany I know you
wonder approach that I want you to
because
you were the one who mentioned it about
the apology because this is now a non
statue way the Society's remember their
history and you know but you mentioned
Ireland but it was interesting that in I
think it was around 2000 Tony Blair did
give this apology maybe it was a bit
later for the British culpability for
the famine in Ireland and there was one
there were two kinds of hostile
responses one was you know kind of Union
this position we said there's nothing to
apologize for but there was another one
that said even if there is something to
apologize for what meaning does it have
a man who was born you know a century
and a half after it happened to stand up
and apologize for something he had no
involvement in and there are other cases
on a sliding scale of proximity to the
event from David Cameron apologizing for
Bloody Sunday through no breaks it
though but not breaks it to to Pope John
Paul the second apologizing for you know
two millennia of Catholic persecution of
Jews so what meaning does apology have
when when we do that um I think it's
really novel actually that political
leaders apologize in the way they have
done since around there since about 1990
onwards Tony Blair also expressed regret
for the slave trade he didn't formally
apologize and they're obviously people
like John Howard who wouldn't apologize
for the way straighter treated the
Aboriginal people I think you have to
ask why and who benefits and what are
the implications I think they try and
gain some sort of moral legitimacy out
of it it makes it's a grand icing for
Tony Blair and it makes him look good
because he can say we are not like those
people in the past we know slavery is
wrong and there's a kind of real moral
flattery to it
I think it's insidious and that it
divorces responsibility from action I
think that's the most important thing in
politics is to take responsibility for
one's own actions and I think it lets
political leaders off the hook for
inequalities today because a they're
making themselves look good and B they
can say well it's really because this
thing happened 200 years ago it's really
nothing to do with us although we are
awfully sorry about it so I think it is
inhibiting politically I don't think
it's progressive well I think
I don't have any problem with modern
figures apologizing for past wrongs for
one simple reason everybody in this room
will have heard somebody say we won the
war or we won the World Cup in 1966
regardless of whether they were alive in
1945 or 1966 there is a tendency to be
very comfortable celebrating one's own
part in things that we had no
involvement in but when it comes to
things that were bad it's a total
nothing to do me I wasn't alive then you
know move on so you know there's a huge
it's one of the many inconsistencies and
the many hypocrisy is in the way that we
remember these aspects of the past the
reality is there is a very good reason
why no senior British politician has
ever apologized for the transatlantic
slave trade biggest atrocity against
humanity in human history the reason is
because it would open up the way to a
very a very legitimate case for
reparations and no politician is willing
to lay the ground that would help a
reparations case because it would have
legs legally there is a strong case
there were 14 Caribbean nations
currently litigating for reparations
because of Britain's involvement in the
transatlantic slave trade and so the
specter of reparations is borrowing
politicians from admitting something
which had long ago being admitted which
was that Britain was one of the
inventors and major benefactors of a
trade that trafficked in people that has
an intergenerational legacy that affects
people's lives today and if we just look
at the spectrum wind rushes brings me
right back to statues one of the things
that I really took away from the recent
stories about the wind regeneration is
how many of them were enduring the this
refusal to have NHS treatment eviction
by landlords without going to their MP
or without speaking to journalists
without raising the flag and the reason
is that they lived although they should
have been British although they had been
here so long they lived in a state of
insecurity there are so many people who
are entitled to be in this country who
are British who do not feel able to
claim their full place in this state and
the way that statues commemorate their
oppressors is one of many complex ways
in which we still deal Ajit's mize the
Britishness of people of color in
Britain and it's something we cannot
afford to keep ignoring Peter
you you in our initial go around were
quite skeptical of the importance of the
statues issue and said you know there
are other things would if people on this
side of the argument were more
campaigning about reparations and saying
you know put aside the statues we would
rather see reparations for the
descendants of slaves with that in a way
strike pass your test of whether
something matters or not more now I
think that's it that's it just a
question of law isn't it it's about how
does one how does one settle things that
have been done that are wrong and I
think that it's a it's a question but
above my competence to work out how one
how one addresses that and you know like
most people in the world I would like
the most relevant and most competent
court to be able to listen to the
arguments to make a ruling and that's a
political judgment isn't it well I think
yeah it has a society do we want to
compensate yes I mean I'm not going to
waste anybody's time say well where do
where you draw a line and here we have a
reparation for the Norman invasion of
1066 this is obviously it's a
fundamentally important question that
are frustrating and it's one that is
meaningful right it's not one about
that's a joke it's one that it's
absolutely serious personally in the in
the in the scheme of things the statues
are much less useful than education and
by not just explaining what the past
meant or what about how what we can do
about it and that education means being
politically informed of being
understanding what levels of exclusion
there are in society for people from the
wrong backgrounds the wrong skin color
wrong gender or sexuality and so on
because all of us on balance I'd have
thought in the in this hopefully in this
room would agree agree that we should be
a country that is based on equality and
based on merit right and how one
achieves that is a slightly different
story that it doesn't seem to me that
pulling a few statues down would make a
big difference to those kinds of debate
I'd like to see something that's much
more substantive right but having said
that you know I work on places like
Russia for example where no one had any
question at all in 1990-91 that Lenin
statue should be pulled down for all
over the world i'ma fall over the xov
Union and no one in their right mind I
thought today would think that there
would be a good idea for them to go back
up although there was a real revisionism
in some of these countries towards
redirecting a Soviet past of
recalibrating what the Soviet Union
meant and you know I find it difficult
as someone who has long connections to
this part of the world see people
wearing hammers and sickles right
walking around as though
selling Socialist Worker or or talking
about hard let's say well the seventeen
you've got it wrong but actually it's a
fundamentally good set of ideas you know
that is the same kind of process under
thought that David was talking about
people in Bristol being being horrified
that people could take this kind of
position so there is a kind of deep
cleanse I think we need to go as far as
there follows the question reparations I
think it's out of thought it's how does
one make a sensible reparation to people
seven six seven eight generations down
there is fair and equitable because it's
you know we were almost out of business
anywhere in this country but if we pay
people who are the descendants of the
people who were who are enslaved and
sold with it I mean that's the they
desert it's worth billions hundreds of
billions do you want to go in very brief
on this and then I've got one last thing
for all of you before we go to him on
statues that have come down and if you
go to Budapest you can go to memento
Park and all the communist statues were
put there and likewise in India but they
came down as the social order was
changed they they accompanied social
change rather than this which I think is
in place of it right that's very
interesting
the and he said before he is the last we
want to put all four of you man called
David reef a journalist who recovered
the Bosnian Balkan Wars me in the 90s
wrote a book recently called in praise
of forgetting in which he said that
we've got too much history not just
statues but museums and commemorations
and he said having seen these conflicts
particularly that kind of civil strife
they are entirely rooted he said in an
excess of history where people say much
as you would just think about we were
the victims of you over there and
therefore we must get our revenge and
you see it played out generation after
generation and he says we actually just
need a less of it much less of it and he
quotes the Northern Irish writer who
said you know we need to build a
monument to amnesia and then forget
where we put it that's a much more
radical idea than anything we've we've
done and I'm just curious all for you
are all four of you are historians
of one form or other what do you think
of that idea that it's not just about
statues museums the whole shooting match
is actually a mistake I the volkens is a
really great place to feel crap about
chose choosen to be a historian it's a
place you really question your life
choices when you sit in the cafe in the
Balkans and everyone you talked to has
some burning I say that's right so the
Balkans in this country
is synonymous with tribal blood-shedding
historically from them for the last
thousand years there's been one war
between the Serbs of the crow whither
peoples of that region right one how we
contextualize that in a 20th century or
the 19th century of slavery men dying in
Flanders the Holocaust these are the
unwashed I found the hope of things of
things recovering really difficult to
grasp and really could see how history
was weaponized other places I don't want
to get into the discussion specifically
about the Balkans because we wake as
large as many but it's a world where you
can see that Northern Ireland is one of
them where people are inculcated in the
world a world view in a certain history
which away which is closes avenues I
think that's that's all that that's all
true in it so it's really worrying I
don't think we have too much history in
this country because I think what Peter
was saying about our version of history
is we only tell partial stories so to
talk about you mentioned China I've
never met a Chinese person who doesn't
know that in 1860 the British destroyed
the Summer Palace I rarely meet a
British person who understands that one
of the greatest treasures in Chinese
history one of the great architectural
and and and its contents were destroyed
and looted by the by a British and
French force under the younger Lord
Elgin in the 1860s the idea that we have
a right that we can decide what we
remember and what we forget when it
comes to Empire doesn't work because
there's also then there's also India
hasn't forgot
the repression after the mutiny of 1857
India hasn't forgotten Amritsar India
hasn't forgotten the Bengal famine and
the famines of the 19th century so there
are a lot of people for whom the bitch
we remember it on the bits they
remembering every spunk was there even
if people in India remembering emerita
all this remembering means people cannot
get on with living people remembering
different things - that I understand
he's just he's making a point about
human beings in a way that we just wait
down with these memories but it's a
really good book and it's short and very
nice short essays but I think he makes a
really important point which is that it
can be incredibly divisive and set
people against each other and kind of
the conflict of the past just kind of is
is spread everywhere I think that's what
the kind of reparations campaign could
create and I think it also creates some
people a kind of a victim identity
they're encouraged really to show their
wounds because how are you going to get
reparations if you haven't suffered so I
think it encourages people to feel frail
and and unable to shape their own
destiny when the whole point of
something like decolonization was to
throw us throw off the kind of shackles
of history and shape histories which is
warmer 20d corners universities and
curriculums part of the same process
I've taken control not victims
tyfa and i really seem to you these
retiring cowering victims why don't you
come back and then Peter and then we're
gonna really great summer palace in
Beijing because sometimes people say to
me if you you know if you really want to
move down there take down Nelson
imagine if British people went around
the world destroying their statues and
culture how would they feel to which I
reply that's called the British Empire
you know so many people in this country
have no idea that Britain went around
the world wreaking cultural havoc and
destruction and destroying the heritage
of my own family who lived in Kumasi the
center of the Ashanti Kingdom the
artefacts that the history the
literature
they're lost forever because of the
British raised from the Anglo shanty was
some of them ended up in private
collections summer in the British Museum
but the majority are lost and won't be
recovered I care about history this
isn't about in raising history but this
is about amnesia and you know I feel
like there's a theme in my responses to
Tiffany Tiffany says this is weaponizing
the debate this is weaponizing identity
this is creating victims the reality is
this weaponization has been going on
only it's been going on against a
minority who are not heard the problem
with that but the problem with
remembering less history is who gets to
decide at the moment we remember only
very a very small number of things I
heard a statistic that there are 50 TV
series every year in Britain about the
Second World War
50 every year which rang true and
there's a reason why we're obsessed a
second law well we want it it's it makes
us feel good you know there is a good
narrative we're on the right side of
history we are the moral victors we are
not interested in the historical
narratives that make us feel
uncomfortable about our legacy as
British people so I would be interested
I'm not so worried about less of that
history I want more of the history that
we choose to forget and a greater
understanding of the reasons why we've
chosen to pick okay very close briefing
you Kangas I want to give you yeah you
know I think that's that's a little bit
cynical you know people's aren't in the
second world war because it's humanity
at its most disgusting and most depraved
and there is an educational process in
explaining that what look like decent
normal people are capable of the right
circumstances of committing horrendous
acts against each other you know we're
capable yeah absolutely right and that's
not just a British thing that's a French
thing that's a West African then that's
an East African thing slavery is
something since the dawn of time and if
anybody think slavery today doesn't
exist it was a human trafficking
particularly of young women you know
this is a proper society and global
problem always has been so I'm not
trying to downgrade any of those
experiences but that does always need to
be put a context in in the case of the
second world war some of us because of
the horrors and the reminder to our
children and their children that this
can happen you know that Aleppo is not
because the Syrians are bad people or
because Assad is a particular bad with
power it's not about the Balkans being a
bloody region and so on compared against
Flanders and the Holocaust and so on
people in the wrong terms
are capable of inflicting profound pain
and murdering their neighbors right and
that is something which is important to
teach to children and in that sense
slavery statutes are part of what how do
we understand history what should we be
teaching and you know I do go back it's
a wine civilizations this series are so
important is to open up that world it's
not just about Western European art it's
not just about the story that we sort of
know with a bit of tweaks there are
billions of people on this planet and
they are all excluded their histories
and their good bits their bad bits their
their equivalents and so on so you know
I think that it's important that we put
that in a context where we are looking
constantly at the whole of the ecosphere
around us thank you
let's go for questions from all of you
and or some of you more realistically so
we'll go with question you're number two
there on that microphone if you go you
go now you know we live in age of images
you know and also political symbolism
you know just look at Trump he's a
political performer so symbolism is is
becoming more and more political so I do
agree that statues might be neutral but
removing the statues is is about symbols
and it's money it could send a much
stronger signal so it's not your
question if you have this age would you
think about the act of removing the
statues as a powerful political message
thank you okay and here yeah and the
debate about Koston is happening in
Bristol and there are things being
renamed and that's happening constantly
there's still an awful lot of things
going on behind the scenes Colston day's
cost and buns Colston relics that are
still hanging around Bristol do you not
think that it's easier to develop that
to bait to spark more debate to have
that Colson statue they're more
important than Neptune statue and that
it should be reinterpreted so you mean
the act of having you there is good
thing because it keeps this debate gay
yes thank you very good then microphone
number three yeah I just was interest
because you said that one of the
solutions would be to bring these
statues in museum and talk about it
because the starches show imperial past
and help
matic it is but museum as institutions
can be very problematic because they are
a part of the Empire of England actually
so how would that solve the problem and
when you say that you mean something
like for example the British Museum with
its treasures from all it yes that's
sort of okay that's interesting and
thank you and then we've got back for a
number if you've got somebody else here
you have okay yeah let's take a fall for
me yep and equality that the black
community who are taxpayers should be
subsidizing the memorials and
initiatives of others without a memorial
of our own now I'd like to actually put
this into context give me an example
women yes well for example there are
many government-funded memorials so for
example in 2002 the barley memorial 2007
the Hyde Park Memorial okay 2015 the
Holocaust and later this summer there's
going to be a new Tavistock memorial and
the chair of the Tavistock memorial said
it's important that 13 innocent victims
aren't forgotten that's correct
and also the memorials I've cited it's
correct that those victims shouldn't be
forgotten but what about Africans 400
years of slavery and yet there is no
memorial to remember them
oh they're lives worth remembering thank
you
I understand and because we've got we've
covered a big range here but when we'll
take one more over there that might
friend number four and then we're going
to bring it back for responses here yes
hi history is written by the winners
education is massively important my big
bugbear with history in the First World
War is that very few people know about
the Berlin to Baghdad railway where
Germany was expanding its empire and
this is not taught in our schools
so I've liked reinforced you of what
you're saying people about education and
do the panel collectively think that
things like the Berlin's Baghdad railway
should be made more available in our
school to have a balanced view on both
sides
thank you let's um thanks for all of
those we will we'll see if we can get
more in why don't we just put to you
David this first point it's a Bristol
point about Colson that you know you did
nominate him for removal right at the
beginning and the questioner says
actually it's good it's got a whole
debate going the perhaps otherwise might
not have happened in Bristol he has
another debate and the debates being
gone being got going by a bunch of
academics and activists who began this
about thirty years ago and have faced
huge resistance from the City Council
from up until recently the newspapers at
every step of the way it's largely down
to match dresser and it's interesting
that it took a visitor a newcomer to our
city a Californian Jewish lady to
actually help this look on fronted City
I've lived in Liverpool I lived in
London two cities at the center of the
Atlantic slave trade Bristol is more in
denial of its history of a jewelry store
than any city I don't think the idea
that the statue is waters brought this
debate I think that debate has been
enlivened by that huge efforts of people
who I enormously admire for the work
that they've done the nice that they're
still doing we had a ceremony last week
in Bristol where we gave sugared buns to
children in honor of a man who sold
bought and sold human beings and was
responsible we estimate for thirty
thousand deaths it's just this is the
21st century we have to decide if we
want to be a society that wants to do
this stuff does somebody and this is the
same thing with roads does somebody
who's made an awful lot of money doing
terrible things have the right to buy
moral absolution are we going to be
complicit in them saying I've bought
forgiveness I bought absolution and for
200 years are we gonna go along with
this it's God that was advocate let's
say we took him down to put David
Beckham well I don't know who the most
famous I mean no or someone we all
agreed was a good thing with no bad side
there are not many of them the academic
world I can tell you notes let's say we
took him down and did the saint of roads
and all the contested spaces that I
can't disagree with him word all of that
but then then they get there do they
don't get away with it that way because
their names then you can take the point
then there they get reduced from history
because no one talks about that anymore
in silence and you know all publicity is
good publicity is one of the good things
about the road must fall campaign that
people have been talking about what
roads meant what he did who he was and I
don't want to do you know as well
editing the historical record is always
complicated but there are different
solutions and so on but getting people
angry getting people to know about hurry
was education again that's the
cornerstone pieces on Stinnett statues
aren't a delivery system for history
your work the books that you sell around
the world of that television programs of
the delivery system these are forms of
memorialization they're not neutral
they're not saying here's the past make
up your view about it come to a decision
they're saying this man was good or
great but the state proves it plays a
role were virtuous son duplicity well he
wasn't a son of the city lived in London
right he wasn't very wise cuz he they
lost the monopoly under his would you
think you mentioned the campaigners in
Bristol and your you know supporters
before thing who would those campaigners
or you like to see on that space which
is currently cause you wouldn't replace
it with anyone I gave for David so we
heard earlier this solution proposed
solution was to move some of these
difficult and controversial statues into
museums or they can be contextualized
and discuss and the questioner over
there said much as you did actually that
they are themselves problematic and the
point was made there about the British
Museum which is in some ways not in the
way you intended a museum of empire
because it records treasures that were
taken around the world you've written
very directly about that the book we
refer to in when I introduced you so
what about that the notion actually
museums have there's a whole other can
of worms with what's in a museum because
we're there's a whole lot of plundered
items there that don't actually send
perhaps the but the message we want
but they're also very busy they're busy
and they're full and they've got a job
to do I want to come back to a point
that David made which is that they are
there an argument of these statutes and
in a way I think that's one of the
functions because one of the hardest
things when I teach students is getting
them to imagine the past as a different
place to the present you know that
historical imagination is really hard
and teaching slavery or talking to
students about slavery is actually quite
hard because they'll say well it's a
terrible thing and people in the past
were terrible people but it's really
hard to trying and deliver a message and
get them to understand that actually
people thought very differently than the
way that they do now and some of the
artifacts from the past there's a the
Museum of Docklands has got quite a
interesting exhibition now with a lot of
anti-slavery iconography little pots and
things like that
which showed the African is a supplicant
waiting to be kind of saved and those
artifacts from history dubious as we may
feel them can actually open up a little
so it's not I'm not saying every statue
should be saved for that I think that'd
be ridiculous
but erasing things that we don't like
doesn't necessarily serve the purposes
of history or opening up the historical
imagination but I just want to come on
to the point about symbols because yeah
it's a really important point and that's
my problem this question just to remind
you about the question this was the
question who said that the act of
removing them would itself be very
symbolic that's correct
oh yeah you go it's limited and that's
why it's only because it's just politics
by symbols and I think you know
Millicent Fawcett is now in Parliament
Square I mean who can argue with that
she's the most vanilla female
suffragette campaigner going and I just
think about women's rights today what
about equality does it just don't
Millicent Fawcett because people have
made that point that she was a
suffragette and not somebody who thought
you know any means necessary do you
think it would have been there were
edgier choices that could have been made
and should they be made um there were
idea traces but I just wouldn't go to
statues I really wouldn't and I feel we
David I'm yeah I'm actually on this one
I'm reminded of the Iraq war when
was a taking down of the statue of his
Saddam Hussein with 2003 yeah who was
who was involved well the Americans were
so they wanted to be part of that
symbolic removal and it was empty and
they helped destroy the country but they
helped take down the statue I mean
that's where symbolism gets you it's a
very limited political strategy it was
extremely effective we only know about
because of a footnote in an an appraisal
of the operation that was accidentally
left him when he was published it was
American Cyclops he was extremely
effective and it shows the symbolism of
statues but I think they sort of messed
up didn't they because they put the flag
on and then quickly removed it there was
an American flag on it they put on then
they had put an Iraqi flag yeah to make
it was all managed by a Marine colonel
and accidentally the reporter just
quickly or whatever it was you're gonna
say because I wanted to say so Peter I
won't to put to you the question it was
made here which is there are statues
only you were the very opening sort of
saying you know we should have other
things to do but the question you hear
made the very good point that they're
asked for morals to all kinds of things
you know the barley attack and the 7/7
attack is about to get it anymore
in that context wouldn't you think and I
know your larger point about we're too
interests elective anyway sure but given
that we do have these memorials at 7-7
and other things a question are asked
surely the victims of 400 years of
slavery deserve some kind of memorial
well you know why are moronic
politicians can't see that do something
about it rather than apologizing all the
time is a mystery to me so you would
favor that kind of absolutely I mean how
could how can anybody argue it without
you know as a scholar in more museums
and more we curate are things the better
so I think that of course that's right I
mean it's it's it's it's it's incredible
to me that we don't have this already
but you need political will
you need funding and you need to be fun
in the humanities so that's all part of
the same script you know I think with
all these things my I was thinking about
on on the way I've been to Oxford you
know the most important collection of
statues that answer though you know
replacement is it political and so on of
course in it's not just in London it's
matter of two songs right that's where
the most statues are in this and his
missus visited by millions tens of
millions people a year and at certain
point you know you unscrew
Paul Daniels his head he put make mega
mark along top right
Peter we know Megan mortal statue know
her her statues just gone up in there
and you the people who were the heroes
alone when I was growing up brought
holiday me he's gone melt it down you
know pull Danielson the first outrageous
thing I feel Kevin Keegan you know I
think that there is there is there is
you know you that your winds of history
they blow through us all and you know we
learned from our past we learned that
what used to be appropriate you know I
used to go to you know Saturday night
watching Benny Hill I had no idea how
utterly grotesque I couldn't but I mean
I couldn't watch that room I couldn't
even explain to my children what that is
and yet at the time it was completely
totally normal and you know the job of
historians is to provide a context for
what that was and how do we move on how
do we learn so I'd much rather on
balance have a museum to Empire or
slavery and to Africans who you know who
on whom this country's wealth was built
then a museum to Benny Hill but you know
you need to have the political goodwill
and the energy and the resource to get
that done and we have a highly fractious
political establishment but you know
Michael Gove when he was education
secretary was asked there was a big
consultation process done with academic
historians about what should be taught
in schools and Nick Clegg who's a friend
of mine was at the was at the meeting
where Michael Gove was handed this
policy paper I asked it was it all right
if I say this in the public domain he
said trust me you say whatever you like
my gogo pulled out a piece of paper from
his pocket that said right here the
kings of Queens in England so I like the
idea that you should learn about been in
and you know 10th century but actually
this is what I think kids should learn
and won't with a tick going Elizabeth
first you know Henry the eighth that's
all and so forth all those usual things
and if you don't have the resources Alex
in the gentleman's question there if you
don't teach about the interconnected
world if you don't show how Britain
India the Caribbean North America was
connected together then you've lost your
children by the time they become you
know by the time they're 11 or 12 for
there was only one question left that we
haven't yet address but I'm quite get
some morning but this was the person who
raised the thing about the Berlin to
Baghdad railway and will want meaning
even those things we can we do learn
lots about there's always aspects that
we don't issue about the reason that we
are obsessed with second war is because
it's a story of human pathos and what
they're the atrocity that humanity is
capable of
I agree but
same time even within that we don't
learn the whole picture so my
grandfather was Kindertransport from
Berlin for as a Jewish refugee from Nazi
Germany I didn't learn about that I
didn't learn about the the hostility
towards Jewish refugees in Britain in
the early thirties newspaper headlines
regarding us that the scum of Europe the
narrative we've received is that we were
very benevolent we opened up the borders
to do a charity we only accept an
unaccompanied children you know even at
the time there are things that I think
it's important as a context for
understanding how people fleeing a
threat like the Nazi presence in Germany
90s we still didn't understand and you
know in Germany they've got two
different words for monuments they've
got monuments that make you think about
the past and they've got monuments that
warn you about not what not to repeat
either of us it's not a coincidence we
don't have a sophisticated language
because we don't have a sophisticated
relationship with statues and monuments
I think that the reason it's important
to remember these histories is to avoid
repeating them and even within the
histories we think we know a lot about
we avoid aspects that do not fit a
narrative as their as the moral victor
as the nation was on the right side of
history I just wanted to address the
point about the you know the problem
with museums you know museums the
Academy the school and university
curriculum they are all colonial
institutions I agrees that museums are
not a necessarily a safe space but this
is a completely cyclical problem you
know we have statues that are part of
our tendency to revere a colonial past
and we don't want to take them down
because any of the places we could put
them also Revere a colonial past and
this is really and I totally agree with
David about this this is not really
about statues it's about cultural
attitudes towards history it's about our
relationship with our past it's about
our contemporary identity and our
imagined identity in the past and just
to finish what Tiffany said of course
the past was a different place but one
of the things we downplay in my opinion
is the history of resistance you know
working-class protest against things
like slavery the fact that in the mill
towns of northern England people whose
livelihood depended on the cotton trade
from the slavery South went on strike in
support of slaves these are white
working-class people who had no reason
other than their conscience and their
morality to take a stance against the
transatlantic slave trade we also don't
remember them there are so many things
we forget because it's not convenient
and I would like to see them all back in
the record for debate let's not talk
about the Guardians editorial position
would be another interesting
conversation Garden sided with the
concentrators are not the striking
workers and sided with the south and the
Civil War extraordinarily that's another
identity now let's just take in a couple
two or three more questions just in a
these are gonna have to be so brief
because we're really almost running out
so if we can get a microphone over to
hear if we're talking about political
figures I mean there'll always be
something negative about rulers or
leaders like Churchill for example you
know the fact remains that Churchill was
the prime minister during the war and he
did leave the country but there are also
a lot of negative stories about
Churchill but if his statue is up there
I mean is it justified to remove it and
can we only have statues of people like
Florence Nightingale and Mother Teresa
just behind you thank you can we only
have statues for people who are
unambiguously good an angelic yeah so
thanks so much for this debate I'm I'm
in Bristol as well I'm part of the
countering Coulston group that has been
campaigning Bristol for these changes
okay you asked what what campaigners
would want so I can speak to that the
next thing that we are campaigning for
is to get a Memorial in Bristol a
memorial and a museum to honor slavery
resistance and abolition we don't have
to wait for this to happen from up above
everybody in this room can help to make
this happen
we'll start we're going to launch
crowdfunder and anybody who wants to
help make this happen we can you know we
can do it now so is there a question or
is it yes no that's fine thank you let's
see the question over there yeah what is
the criteria by which we remove statues
I mean you mentioned one criteria which
is it is offending to someone and as an
example you mentioned T you know statues
by the Nazi regime in Germany
which of course are offending to Jews
now I am from Germany and I can tell you
we are not removing these statues
because they will be offensive to Israel
or to the Jews we are removing them
because we are afraid of ourselves we
removed them because we are afraid that
they become an assembly point for Nazis
and that the atrocities that we lived in
our country are reoccurring we are still
scared of that 70 years after the Second
World War that's why we removed them not
because they are offending their
offending statues all over the world so
the question is you know are you scared
that slavery is coming back or why do
you want to them to be removed
fascinating thank you and your question
goes to this point of how powerful these
things can be and there's a very last
one I think over here this would be the
last one so following on nicely from
that I would ask that when we talk about
removing statues it seems that people
are really afraid of history being
erased histories in the first place
aren't being taught in schools in
anywhere near an adequate level to deal
with Empire and the violence and pain of
that so in Australia at the moment
there's been a call after the statement
from the heart last year for a process
of truth-telling about our history and
the word used means reconciliation after
a struggle but people have been really
afraid because that requires a
recognition of the pain and the harm and
that ongoing violence so what are you so
afraid of if you don't want to take a
statue down great thank you
thanks for all of those sorry for people
we couldn't get in let's
David's big quick one for you you said
at the beginning that if people are you
know I'm ambiguously bad in a way
there's not two sides of the ledger and
you cited Coulson's example then you say
there's not really a case for keeping
the statue up put the other way the
questioner says you know unless they're
Florence Nightingale does that mean they
can't be remembered and we're only going
to end up with these very vanilla was
your word about Millicent Fawcett
statutes is that the risk no that's what
I'm saying at all I also I have a huge
problem
both mother Teresa and Florence
Nightingale and in a way there is no
vanilla figure actually in a way this is
why I think the debates not about about
statues you know I've got no problem
that being said to you to Churchill but
I do have a problem the fact that we
need to tell them more it's a much more
complicated figure much more interesting
figure than the the darkest hour figure
I just want us to be honest about our
history I'm not I don't care about the
statues that much or the care about
deserve being honest about the history
one of the myths about people who debate
these is that this is some form of that
it's all about offense I've never
mentioned defense I don't feel a fencer
then you stat you and it's not about a
sense of victimhood I really don't feel
and I presume you don't feel I carry
myself like a victim it's to do with I
think we can become a better country I
think we're good enough strong enough
honest enough country to confront our
history the good and the bad I think
we're up for I think would where we can
do it I just would be happier to live in
a country that wasn't in denial of our
parts of its past great because time is
so short
I'd like the three of you to take them
that those last two questions both which
had fear in them the German example and
then the examples from Australia but
both were saying what are you afraid of
about either keeping these statues or
removing them why don't we start with
you Tiffany oh it's a really good point
about your about Germany but you see I
think there that there is a huge
distrust of the public and I think there
is here too and I that makes me feel
very uncomfortable it's not that I think
the public Arthur you know it's
wonderful smart group of people but I
think we have to treat them with a
little bit of respect and not like their
Pavlovian dogs who can't see a statue
not turn into some sort of Nazi oh the
woman was killed last year at the base
of this chat you two generally the
far-right the Nazi the KKK are rallying
around these statues and people have
died what Steve Bannon say he said as
long as they're talking about statues
we've got them ma I I think there's a
kind of circle where the old right and
the whatever you might want to call it
are kind of reinforcing a battle over
statues I think you just need to Deepa
little sighs it entirely but they are
dangerous because they I don't think
they're dangerous I mean in the case of
the war having a challenge feel that it
was the removal that triggered thee it
wasn't the history was no no it was
about the statute in Charlotte it was
yeah it was a lightning rod people have
using they always have to use these
attitudes yeah to rally around let me
because where he needs to why we're
already over time sorry I'm talking of
you but I just know make sure we wrap it
up so after the the question there was
you know in Germany they have they felt
a very good reason not to put these up
because they were worried about the big
rallying points here in a way what is
the I'm just channeling what the
questioner said what are you afraid of
that might happen if these statues these
revering objects remain in place and he
put it sort of rhetorically are you
afraid slavery will come back if you
keep Nelson up there on a plinth on a
pedestal so slavery was the
manifestation of an ideology of white
supremacy which has not gone away and it
bares itself out in so many parts of
contemporary life in the UK black
afro-caribbeans schoolboys are 168 times
more likely to be excluded in the white
kids youth unemployment are over for
young black men is is double what it is
for young white people fifty percent of
people of black African heritage live in
poverty which is more than 2 times the
rate for other people who live in
poverty the reality is that we have not
recovered from these traumatic histories
they are part of our everyday life and
we constantly live in a state of amnesia
where we call this the the ancient
history that people who raised it are
told that their victims
sort of the fact that we are simply
introducing facts into the debate what
the lady from Australia made such an
Australia's going through a very
interesting conversation right now I
know
exactly what we are afraid of
Britishness is a fragile identity right
now we cannot withstand questioning
interrogating and talking honestly about
historical record that is the real
problem here and I agree with David the
statues are a symptom and not a cause
the real issue is our fragility our
insecurity our hostility and having a
very honest conversation about who we
are and how we got here and that is why
we need to have this debate thank you
and a beter closing for me not sure
that's much dad I mean I of course agree
with with what Allah says and you know I
I just think all of these things are not
affected by lumps of rock these are they
are highly symbolic I think we all agree
with that I mean it's a it's a great
apocryphal story about medieval Italy
where a town attacked Seville
city-states
attacks a neighboring town and they're
led to one of them well as in Tuscany
has led to salvation by a particularly
charismatic leader and the town they
gather round to say well what should we
do to commemorate this great victory of
we all know - victory from the jaws of
disaster and the town's folks say well
we should we should make him our ruler
and this in their City stayed with
highly democratic and then the next one
says we should make a statue to him and
they said that's no good because a
statue will stay up for a while and then
it'll be torn down and then some of the
back says kill him make him a saint and
that gives you perpetuity so you know I
think that these these are there I
recognise the discussions and the
importance about statues as symbols they
do have lightning-rod moments you know
roads and culture - particularly famous
examples but you know half of the Oxford
colleges were founded by people murdered
their wife had to pay penance and it's
how far back you go in all of this it
sits at my vanilla ending is that you
know that is why you have world-class
academic institutions here where you and
it doesn't work without you giving up
your evenings and coming to hear us talk
it doesn't go without you buying a David
a Tiffany's hair for us terrific books
very different in their scope but all
trying to do something similar which is
to ask questions about who we are right
and the only way you can start to learn
is to start by listening so thank you
[Applause]
we thank you very much we cannot leave
without this Peters just said point out
that all four of our speakers have books
that they are happy to sign outside I
leave you with two things first the
words inscribed itched into the ceiling
here you may not notice close with
neither shall there be any more pain for
the former things are passed away so
they are mindful of her history and how
it does that past but I thought that I'd
promised you for people who were going
to grapple with these themes and I think
they've done so extraordinarily
substantively and engage idli and so
your joy it remains for you to join me
in thanking saving all Shaka for her Sh
Tiffany Jenkins aunty - Frankie fan
thank you all very much
[Applause]